I've had a lot of this story for the
better part of 10 years in various you
know ways and just got serious about
writing it about five or six years ago
but the one thing that I always had was
this character of a sailor coming back
from the war there's an attraction to me
to that era
I mean besides just the obvious you know
great great costumes great music you
know that's kind of food and drink
really - if you get a chance to do this
to kind of time travel a little bit and
try to understand what was going on you
know my father was around during that
time so you probably and he's not around
anymore so probably in an effort to kind
of understand better what his
experiences were I probably was digging
around to see what it was like looking
after the war sort of all this optimism
but just a tremendous amount of
destruction in the background and that
probably gets a great dramatic situation
to serve for these characters I think
and kind of a good venue to tell a story
and that you have to kind of let that
stuff go teeny bit like there's
musicologist out there probably who
would kill us for using get thee behind
me Satan which is like two two years
after our time in the film which is like
probably an absolute no-no to some
people but you just have to fudge the
details a little bit and sure hopefully
nobody notices my influences are long
and huge and we keep Turner classics on
in my house all the time so it's just
like a 24-hour kind of IV of information
and feeling and and you know if you're
cooking breakfast and you look over and
you can see something that somebody did
you know 60 years ago you think man you
know and hopefully it just gets in you
and and and and and you know you sort of
can go into a film maybe sort of
thinking about ideas or the films that
you've seen but days into it when the
clock is ticking and the schedule is
moving at a pace it's it's just you just
hopefully sort of become yourself and
you're just trying to sort of film it
right and uniquely and and
and simply and that's sort of the thing
that I love about most films is you see
on turn of classes just just how how
muscular and strong and simple they are
I'd always wanted to work with Joaquin
I've tried to work with him before and
it never worked out and this was just a
kind of this is the opportunity that
came up and the time was right and the
character was right and there was a
great mutual admiration and respect
between Philip and Joaquin and and I
think a kind of excitement to to act
with each other so yeah that interested
that I feel the same way about Aimee as
well I wanted want to try to find a way
to work with her since I first saw and
and fill his work with her before so she
was dynamite and then everybody else in
the film you know it kind of like a lot
of people are just starting out a lot of
sort of great young actors amber
Childers and Jesse Plemons remi malik
and the list goes on sort of great great
young actress who were just starting out
who really came did a great job you know
I was curious about these old
VistaVision cameras then sort of how
like North by Northwest and vertigo
ended up looking like that so we sort of
had the idea of trying to mess around
with some of those cameras not not to
recreate that look but just as a way to
kind of use some old gear and equipment
that might be lying around and so we
just started testing stuff out we
started testing a lot of old lenses over
at Panavision and sooner or later Ella
that works over their dances Aki
suggested us trying these 65 cameras
that they had that have been used here
and there lately Chris Nolan's been
using them and Robert Robert used them a
couple times anyway so we started
shooting with them and the results just
felt right it felt like obviously very
sort of very rich but and it kind of
could it could help you you know create
ideally that kind of that thing that
happens when the movie theater goes dark
that you kind of time-travels that you
hope you're watching a story that
actually is taking place with with
people with real lives and acting them
out as they they did act them out and
the farthest I got long in thinking
about it was um you know maybe we'll be
able to make a 70 print but I
ultimately that most people would be
seeing a 35-millimeter reduction or so I
thought I mean little in the five years
I've since I've made a film a lot has
happened and there's a lot more digital
theaters than I I was really naive and
realizing thinking about this so at the
very least I thought we'd have a couple
70 prints and you know sort of lo and
behold as this thing sort of unraveled
and the films about to come out you know
people come out of the woodwork and
we've got we're gonna have a 16 prints
total and they'll play in different
theaters across the country in the world
and that has just been a kind of a
miracle that we've been able to do that